this is this is a big one and I've seen
this one really take a life of its own
that you want to do a nuclear
first-strike on the Muslim world right
is that true Sam no no alas it's not
true okay I guess why did they do their
that it was made made true apparently or
at least to the satisfaction of many
people by Chris Hedges who went around
in every stop on his book tour
radio television print telling people
that this was in fact my position and
many people like glenn greenwald and
reza aslan and your old colleague
jankura have have reiterated this claim
there are a couple of passages in the my
first book the end of faith where I talk
about how a certainty about paradise and
about martyrdom is the best way to get
there just destroys the logic of nuclear
deterrence of mutually assured
destruction that we had that kept us
more or less poised on the brink of
mutual annihilation with the Soviet
Union for so many years and I just
pointed out what I think is an obvious
fact and still as an obvious fact should
be an obvious fact and a very troubling
one that if you have a regime that has
the the that is the psychological
equivalent of the 19 hijackers but
people who woke up in the morning
wanting to fly a plane into a building
that is a regime who you can't they're
not rational actors you can't or if
they're rational it's they're rational
within the context of believing that
they're going to paradise right this way
right so what's the official part of
that you know but it's right if you
believe that it's rational to blow up
the world
you know it's rational to hit the wall
at four hundred miles an hour so this is
not so I pointed out the obvious fact
that we have to avoid this circumstance
at all cost and there's no one who
should be more cognizant of this problem
than so-called moderate Muslims or so
are secular Muslims or non-jew hottest
you know
Muslims and we have to collectively find
some path to a alternative future in
which you don't have a true jihadist
regime armed with long-range nuclear
weapons and all of those so long-range
is crucial and so you have Pakistan
Pakistan already has nuclear weapons do
I think we should execute a nuclear
first strike on Pakistan No Pakistan is
not first of all a jihadist regime and
though you know there 1ku away from
being taken over by one but they're also
they don't have the warheads that can
deliver these nukes to the capitals of
Europe or to the US it's a very
different circumstance and so yes no
there's nothing that I say in that book
that suggests that we should be nuking
Iran you know and so it's just this is
all I was talking about is how the kind
of game theoretic logic of nuclear
deterrence that we lived however
precariously under with the Soviet Union
falls apart once you admit to yourself
that it's possible that truly suicidal
religious maniacs can get their hands on
these weapons and so all I was calling
for is is our awareness that is a that
really is a game changer and we have to
avoid that at all cost right and you
know you said this was just a few
passages in your book it was literally
about a page right it's like a paragraph
or two yeah right
so when people have blown this up into
into some something that somehow this is
like this massive idea that you have
actually a good friend of mine who I
agree with on a lot of things and
disagree on some other things he what he
says to me in relation to this is that
you're laying the philosophical
groundwork for a nuclear first-strike
though the people respond to this
passage as though I invented nuclear
weapons or that I think they're a good
thing I'm just talking about the reality
of our world we have a we have a nuclear
policy right we have a first strike
policy we have a someone somewhere in a
war room has has beaten out every choice
point in terms of what are the
circumstances where we would use nuclear
weapons first what are the circumstances
where we would do where we
would where we would imagine that
they're going to be used against us
first and then have to preempt that and
this has all been thought out in a Cold
War context we haven't had to worry
about anyone else doing this to us and
when you're talking about other regimes
like China or North Korea there are
there's a plausible assumption that
they're not suicidal then that everyone
isn't eager to die right right and now
we are talking about a set of ideas you
know jihadist eschatology is just this
idea that that martyrdom is a real
metaphysical principle and it's not only
ok to die in the right circumstances
it's the best possible thing that can
happen to you and that there really is
there's no such thing as innocent
collateral damage as all the good people
are going to go to paradise with you and
they're just going to thank you for it
right yeah so there's nothing can go
wrong and this world is just fit to be
destroyed that is the ideology that you
see in a happily small minority of
Muslims at this moment but it is not an
accident that these people feel this way
because it's it's a very plausible
literal reading of the text
you